[Music]
good morning everyone thank you for
being here it is a pleasure to share the
this conference with you we're going to
be talking today about how you think
about security securing the access to
your data to your applications when you
come to use EPM we've really done a lot
of we've been working very hard we have
a lot of interesting new concepts to
share with you so we're going to take a
holistic approach about how to think
about the security and access control
securing your data when you're coming to
a Google cloud platform
my name is sinasohn bit by the way I'm a
product manager in cloud and I'll be
sharing the stage with samraat who's
another product manager I will have the
pleasure to have here two sigma who is a
customer who will be sharing their
journey to the cloud and how they use
Google security and then we will have
finally walked through partnerships and
the ecosystem that we're building as
well so with that let's get started
how are we thinking about Google cloud
platform security in your deployment so
when you move your deployments to the
cloud and it is important that you are
able to maintain your same security
posture that you have today for your
deployment but then when it comes to the
implementation on the set up of policies
the enforcement of those it really it
really it really requires a little bit
of a change of mindset the reason is
that there are a lot of different type
of deployments there are infrastructure
as a service for example with VM
instances there can be as well google
cloud google kubernetes deployments
there could be as well Google managed
services for example storage or bigquery
and it is important that we provide a
holistic approach for security for for
all of them so for example if you take a
storage Google Cloud Storage it is
really the access to the data is through
api's that means that and those services
are really managed by Google so that
means that when you are applying
securities you will need to control the
policies in a different way because it
needs to be based on really attributes
and conditions that are extracted from
those API calls so that you can restrict
the access for example to the data from
a specific sources and you can as well
have the ability to restrict
exfiltration so that for example API
calls cannot really take the data
outside two destinations that are not
trusted by you how are we looking at the
framework for setting up policies so
leveraging on our very vast
infrastructure will recommend that you
are setting up policies first on the
edge so that meaning the edge is like if
you're explicitly announcing public Apps
for example through load balancers you
can set up those policies that we are
going to enforce in our front end and we
have a large infrastructure to mitigate
the tax and I will talk a little bit
more about that and then from there you
go to the code where the inputs are
hosted in cloud another another concept
that I will be talking in the framework
is we are enable setup of policies that
can be centralized managed but also
their context aware so meaning that when
you are setting up your policies it is
not only networking construct that you
can use but also identities the
resources the price from in which you're
accessing the data
so let's walk through that framework so
how do you think about setting up the
access control to your resources so Fred
first if you're exposing public facing
applications you should be considering
setting up the policies with cloud armor
to expose those cloud armories you can
think of it as a web application
firewall it applies to HTTP HTTPS load
balancers it also applies to see our tcp
ssl proxy load balancers and then it can
actually mitigate attacks at application
layer or an l3 l4 at the edge and we
really are enforcing those policies in
our front ends which are distributed
around the globe now as you are going
into your private deployments you may
want to think of setting up a perimeter
in which you consider your deployments
trusted and we are allowing that
perimeter to be set up for both VM
deployments kubernetes engine
deployments and also for Google MANET
services and this is really what we will
be spending a lot of time talking about
how we're actually thinking of building
a perimeter for accessing data to those
monitor services finally you have the
capability to apply fine-grained
policies where there are application
specific conditions that need to be
applying the communication within that
perimeter so that you can actually have
a micro segmentation of how your
application and your services talk with
each other so let's walk through
everything together again first think
about how you're protecting your public
applications and then we have a global
answer with cloud armor and that
integrates with identity aware proxy so
that as well you can set up your
conditions of what you allow or deny
based on the identity of the user that
is trying to access those
public facing applications second if you
want to build ten of a macro zone in
which you are considered trusted your
services you can use for this EVMS BBC
level firewalls you can use if it's
Google managed services like storage and
bigquery PPC service control which
expands the concept for this managed
services and we'll talk a little bit
more later and if you're looking at
micro segmentation then you can apply
firewalls based on service accounts
which identified the applications that
are set up within that VPC you can use
network policies for your google
kubernetes deployments and you can as
well use I am for more fine-grained
conditions for who sucks in the data for
your Google managed services so starting
from the edge to the micro segmentation
now cloud armor allows you to set up
your rules language it is a pretty rich
root language which allows you to set up
conditions based on application level
but also l3 l4 so you have a lot of
flexibility to build your rules that
also some some policies and rules that
are pre can so that you can just consume
them for specific patterns when you are
now connecting your trusted applications
if you have either VM instances or you
have kubernetes clusters you can set up
PPC firewalls so that you can set up
your perimeter you can extend that
securely to your on-premises as well and
now this is what we want to share here
specifically with you today now we are
allowing as well to have that concept of
service perimeter for the Google manage
services what that means is that if your
hosted data
in storage buckets in bigquery datasets
you are setting up you can set up
policies which are able to express that
only the access of this data within that
perimeter which can be extended to one
premises is going to allow to access
those buckets so we're actually check in
source control not only the identity the
token identity of the user but we are
much ended up with a source from which
that user is accessing the data
similarly we are also checking when
there is an egress action for example to
write the data that the data it is not
being sent to a destination which
outside that perimeter and then finally
we have a fine-grained control yes
quickly there is a micro segmentation
set of policies using service account is
very convenient service account is the
identity of your jobs you can set up
firewall rules using that identity of
the jobs to set up policy across those
services you can use network policies to
set up the communication control for
your containers and pots is based on
namespaces so you can control which
namespaces can talk to which ones and
you can house as well I am for setting
up more control grain identity access
control to a specific resources in for
example buckets or data sets in bigquery
and with that I really want to spend
some time explaining how we're thinking
about providing that capabilities for
avoiding exfiltration of your data
building that perimeter for your for the
data that you host in either in storage
be query or any of our managed services
I'm going to welcome on stage summer
gray who's the product manager for BPC
service controls and he's going to
explain how this works
Thank You anise
so as Ennis mentioned and she explained
the concepts and principles of security
that you have been utilizing on premise
don't change but the application of
those concepts and principles when you
come to cloud you have to optimize them
for cloud and one of the areas which is
very different on cloud from your own
premise is that of managed services so
we are going to dive a little deeper
into that specific area since the
application is different from how you
are typically used to with sort of l3 or
l4 constructs that you use to create
parameters on Prem so V PC service
controls they effectively it extends
your parameter Security paradigm into
fully managed services services that are
exposed by api's those where the
resources themselves don't have distinct
l3 identities right they don't have
distinct IP addresses which you can
safeguard behind a firewall right in
doing so by providing a parameter
security it helps you mitigate data
exfiltration risks you can also use this
parameter as a way to privately access
your data from DCP but also from
on-premise and I think as Ennis
mentioned if you do want to grant access
from the internet you can use context
awareness to determine the level of
trust in a very application centric
manner versus just the fact that you are
within the network right so you can use
other artifacts to grant access and
finally this is really a tool for
organizational administrators so one of
the challenges with I am traditionally
has been across all public clouds is the
delegation model because I am tends to
be fine-grained policy management a lot
of times I am admins or I am
administration itself of the policies
tend to get delegated and then you have
to do things like monitor for compliance
etcetera which can be painful we have
purposely designed this to be a very
macro cost current posture that you can
implement which the i''m administrators
cannot override so it's a great way to
implement your
sort of mandatory minimum security
controls right and then you can have
further fine-grained application
specific controls defined through iron
so we talked about data exfiltration so
it's important to understand how can
data exfiltration occur from managed
services and why that is an issue on
public clouds so typically what would
happen is that your standard firewall
say your V PC network firewall you would
set a policy like allow all access to
GCS so it would be like storage dot
Google the Google API so um for example
right what that means is you can not
only of access your own buckets you can
pretty much access any buckets right
because your firewall is not aware of
the resource model of GCS up on cloud or
bigquery or for that matter any of the
services that you're consuming that are
fully managed so that leads to certain
risks that you are exposed to the first
is that your I am becomes sort of a
single point of failure for your
security so you have if you have
misconfigured ion policies and they may
be intentional or for malicious reasons
so just for convenience reasons right
you land up accidentally exposing data
and this has been fairly there's it's
been in the news a lot right like this
particular s3 bucket or something else
got exposed and it's fundamentally a lot
of that if you go back and look at the
cause it's the first one but then that's
not the only thing you can have somebody
stealing identities and phishing and
stolen identities are fairly common
right we talked elsewhere about how to
prevent your identities being stolen
using you know you be keys and our
fishing capabilities but nevertheless
you still want to assume that the
identity has been fished or is or the
token has been stolen in which case
somebody could access the data from the
internet pretty much and then drop it
push it to Dropbox
right and that's an excellent raishin
the third is you actually have an
insider who and this is one of the more
difficult things to control for so here
you can just mitigate the risk versus
eliminate the risk in this particular
case but you can mitigate it
significantly
is there either using compromised code
running in a VM or directly accessing
the bucket themselves and running as
simple as a GCS dot copy command that's
all you need right to move the pretty
much terabytes of data from buckets that
you own to public buckets or buckets
that belongs to the attacker right so
these are the parts that we have shown
here which are are exposed to the risk
so effectively what VPC service controls
does is it creates a virtual perimeter
around the resources of your managed
services like GCS buckets or bigquery
data sets and it then also Maps that
parameter to one or more VPC network so
you can simply add your hosts project
where your VPC network is defined into
the virtual service parameter and
therefore all VMs in that network then
have access to the resources within the
parameter within the service parameter
but the VMS don't have access to
resources that are outside the perimeter
so even if you read the data into a VM
you cannot write the data to a resource
that's outside the parameter further
your service to service communications
like copy calls from say GCS copy call
example that I gave or big query trying
to query a GCS bucket these kind of
pathways are also controlled by this
parameter so what it does for you is
allows you to effectively take your data
that's sitting in a fully managed
service and make it private right and it
provides in that sense and ingress
control right controls access from the
internet so access from the Internet is
denied by default and an egress control
so you prevent the copying of data
outside to unauthorized projects instead
covered this so I'll go through this
fairly quickly you can extend this
security posture to your on-prem if
you're connected over VPN or private
interconnect your on-prem machines also
will not be able to if you connect over
if you use this technology and you
access our data privately you will also
not be able to even from on-prem will
not be able to access unauthorized GCS
resources or buckets so your
acceleration control is propagated all
the way to on-premise and lastly if you
do want to open up access you can do
things like only allow access from an
arrange that's sort of the l3 equivalent
but you can do something more
sophisticated like I will only allow
access from a managed device given a you
know Yubikey touch and so on and so
forth right so that gives you this full
context of our access to the parameter
with that I'll show you how you can
easily define these policies and manage
them centrally at scale demo please
great so this product is under private
beta right now so if you're white listed
at this point in time or if you hate for
us to be in the public beta either in
one of those cases you would see a
couple of menu items one that says VPC
service controls the other that says
access context manager so access context
manager is the tool that allows you to
define these sort of access levels that
gives you context of our access but
today we will do a quick demo of VPC
service controls the core product that
allows you to build a parameter so in in
this world what we are going to have is
I'm going to show you while starting up
I'll start building a new parameter and
I'll show you the structure of the
projects that exist so let's just call
it prod parameter and let's look at the
projects so in the project's I'm just
going to filter it by over here so we
can narrow down to the projects that are
relevant to this demo so I've created an
attacker project to represent the
unauthorized project that has a GCS
bucket in it we also have a compute VM
which I'm going to use to explain how
I'm accessing data from within the
network for example right and a storage
project that actually has the bucket
containing PII right so before I create
the parameter I just wanted to show you
a quick exfiltration pass here
sorry
there you go so the one I have got on my
left hand side the menu is on my laptop
so think of it as the client that
connects from the internet right on the
right is I have actually SSH into the VM
that is inside the production network
right so I'm going to first demonstrate
that this is my bucket that is actually
my production bucket the VPS II secure
bucket and I am able to access it from
my laptop which is from the internet and
I'm also able to access it from my
production environment and I can then I
have my attacker bucket which obviously
I should be able to also be able to
access from the internet right it got no
data in it and here's the issue which we
have which is you can also access it
from the production environment right so
here's the exfiltration but it's very
complicated as you will see it's this CP
command that I run over here and I'm
done and now let's look at the attacker
bucket from the internet there you go my
PII is out on the internet right that's
all I needed to do and it's available
now with no ion permissions that because
the attacker bucket is a public bucket
so your data is no exposed to the
internet with just this one CP command
now this is because it's so simple you
do want to mitigate this risk and the
way we mitigate this risk I'm going to
quickly delete the data for
okay
they just delete the data for now from
the Decker bucket but now we'll set up
the actual parameter so we are now going
to add the projects which I just showed
you except for the tracker buckets we'll
add the other buckets into all the other
projects into a service parameter which
I've called prod parameter here so
you'll say and all these three projects
so as you can see I don't have to do
anything GCS specific or big very
specific this is one of the powers of
this control is that it allows you to
have a very homogenous or way of doing
this across different service types now
I say which services do I want to
protect here let's say I want to protect
the GCS API the cloud storage API and
the big table API because those are the
services that I care about so I'm going
to protect those two I don't use an
access level when I don't use an access
level that means there is no access from
the Internet ie the data is private so
let's do that let's save it and there
you go it's now it's created a proper
ammeter as you can see and it has the
three projects in there in there and the
two two services that it's protecting so
let's go back sometimes it takes a
little time to roll out the
configuration because there's a global
configuration but let's give it a quick
try to see if it's in place so now let's
run the copy command again and let's see
what happens ah the access was denied
because you could no longer associate
the data and similarly if you try to now
access the private bucket from the
internet right you will be denied access
to the private bucket from the so now
you have segmented your access your
internet facing client can access the
attacker bucket but not the secure
bucket and your production system can
access the secure bucket but not deep
attacker bucket right so it's now fully
segmented and your exfiltration parts
have been closed up right you can then
grant access pretty simply
using access context manager if you
wanted to grant access from the internet
so you can define different access
levels and then when you go back to your
service controls page you can go back to
your parameter and you can simply decide
which access level do you want to use to
grant access to resources in the service
parameter
right so for example I could choose
something like hi trust and go safe that
means only clients that are within this
definition of hi trust which is in this
higher IP range are allowed to access
the data that's it thank you can we go
back to the slides please
and with that I would like to invite up
on stage our colleagues from our
customers to sigma2 how they have used
this to deployment thanks honey
my name is Nick I work in security my
team is a partner team to Tony's team
and we work very closely together I'm
focusing on public cloud platform
security a lot of what some Rodin
dinners have talked about we use pretty
extensively if you think about our
business in the terms that Tony
described it one of our key assets were
early as our IP and protecting our IP is
really crucial to us so when we think
about threat models and security
controls really were very focused on
trying to mitigate data exfiltration so
I'm gonna talk a little bit about how we
used if we have a full stack of controls
but specifically about V PC service
controls and how we use that in a real
use case for our business
so we had a use case where we had a
research team who wanted to work on
massive datasets so well part of our
business is dealing with external vendor
datasets and often these are huge and
multiple terabytes we had a team who
trialed bigquery and loved it and wanted
to really roll as hard to a production
use case so in order for us to enable
this we had a couple of considerations
and we try to get an MVP up and running
to get this team going as quickly as
possible
but we did have to make a number of
concessions in order to have our
security constraints met and what you
see up on the screen is a very
simplified diagram we had with hand
waved a little what the vendor data
pipeline is but we had a way that data
could get into a GCP project and we
created the CCP project as a standalone
environment that was not directly
connected to our internal network so we
were accessing this over our internet
proxies from inside of two sigma and
what we had to do then is a lot of
extensive research developing iam roles
that were really essentially read-only
there was a moving target so there was a
lot of complexity there and a lot of
tech debt that were racked up but what
we eventually ended up going with was
creating home servers in the GCP project
that were GCE instances worth service
accounts bound to them and the role that
the service account had gave our
researchers and engineers the
permissions they needed to interact with
bigquery and GCS and other core services
the way they accessed those also from
within to Sigma also hand waved a little
is we had a bastion type environment
where we were able to restrict things
like copying and pasting SCP but still
give them shell level access so that
they didn't start to iterate one of the
key benefits here was they were able to
start to work on those data sets and
process them and create research and we
were able to get them up and running
really quickly but there were quite a
few drawbacks as well and I'll hand back
to Tony to talk about some of the
drawbacks yes I was nick said this got
us up and running very quickly but there
were some downsides
we start with the home server this start
this was a real disconnect for our users
so Nick mentioned the bastian access so
this has an additional hop a lot of the
researchers wanted to use tools that
they were used to using on their home
servers inside to sigmah but to actually
get out and play with the data in a
readwrite manner they had to go out onto
the home service to do this this also as
Nick mentioned added the complexity that
we had to deal with two different
identities we had to have a two Sigma
user that was read-only and a external
identity that gave him the full
read/write access another big problem
was the fact that this was connected
over the the the internet and went by a
proxy so often one of the common use
cases the researchers would have is that
they would want to join local to Sigma
data with data that they had from the
vendors and there was no good way for
them to do this because essentially this
was expectation so what they end up
having to do was raise a JIRA they would
put in a request their manager would
have to approve it and then it would go
to Nick and his team and they would then
have to jump onto a secure site and push
the data up and we're talking terabytes
of data multiple times in a week we're
going to coalesce those requests to once
a week and as you can imagine this was a
real problem for trying to remain agile
for our teams uploading was one problem
downloading was also another problem so
the corporate proxies we use these to
ensure that our security parameter is
kept well well put together for users
for internet access but when we had the
research teams wanting to download
terabytes of data but at the same time
we would often find that they would have
either performance problems or actual
terminated jobs and also other
engineering groups completely
independent from into Sigma were
suffering as well so thank you being a
design partner with Google yeah we
didn't want to develop solutions that
were less than optimal or would rack up
even more tech there on our site so we
decided to reach out to Google and we
engaged with the network services team
some write in and as a team we we talked
about our requirements and what our
considerations were
and also what our security model wasn't
and some of the threats that we wanted
to mitigate and serendipitous
serendipitously it worked out that at
the same time they were starting to
develop the concept of what is now VPC
service controls so we spent a lot of
time in design sessions with the product
and engineering teams kind of
understanding what the roadmap was sort
of communicating what our considerations
were and then were really early adopters
we obviously did our validation testing
our sort of form of penetration testing
and then were able to create an
environment that was sort of version two
of what we have here we try to solve
some of the problems that Tony had
highlighted so up there I'm going to let
Tony go into more detail about some of
the steps that we took to address kind
of some of some of those shortcomings
thanks Nick so yeah as you can see the
diagram that's up here is very similar
to what we had before with two really
key differences so one the GCP project
is now in its own secure perimeter and
two the project is directly connected to
two sigma by a private cloud
interconnect now this was this
introduced major benefits for us first
of all users could now safely use all of
the native services directly from inside
to Sigma from their home servers we
didn't have to maintain these dual
identities for them so the I am
complexity that I mentioned before was
essentially removed
additionally now that we're going
directly over the private interconnects
the upload and the download problem
disappeared users good push date with
impunity because there was no
exfiltration risk and they could
download over a pipe which was much much
bigger than what we were delivering by
our standard into the access similar
some side benefits went by removing the
need for these bastian and home servers
we actually reduced the infrastructure
that had to remain in the project to
actually save ourselves some money as
well so ultimately this resulted in a
major velocity jump for the group that
was doing the research and we quickly
realized that this was gonna be
something that was gonna be very popular
throughout the company so what we wanted
to do is to try and standardize this
into a general platform that we could
roll out to anyone now before we did
this there was one technical thing that
we had to overcome and that is that to
use the secure perimeter
access the perimeter project has to
advertise a route back to your internal
network over which you can access all
the AP is and this was fine for doing
this with a proof of concept that we had
here but as you can imagine if we were
doing this for potentially hundreds of
these projects we needed to find a way
that we could scale that and is going to
talk a bit more about that now thank you
again we we didn't want to engineer
something ourselves or to a man with a
hammer everything looks like a nail
we've had success previously working
with the Google team so we decided to
reach back out again and explain what
our new situation was and in this case
again it turned out that it was timely
because Google were thinking about the
concept of how to bridge multiple secure
perimeters together at the time there
was a product or a feature of e PC
service controls called zone bridges and
really this led us to a platform that
you see now at a very high level what
zone bridges are is you can take to
individual parameters and you can create
a bridge between them such that the IP
is can be securely accessed from each
individual project so you can define
essentially multiple different
parameters and when you need them to
interconnect you can have them
interconnect or you can keep them
completely distinct so how we built this
into an architecture that really worked
out for us was we defined a single what
we call like a gateway project for GCP
and really what the role of that was was
twofold
the first role was to advertise that
route back to to Sigma that Tony was
just talking about to access to secure
api's so that was our path into access
to the secure perimeters the other thing
that it did was also represent our
internal network and internal systems
itself as a source secure perimeter so
that we could then bridge that perimeter
with other parameters that we wanted to
grant access to and and enable access to
native Google services from within to
Sigma in a secure fashion so this really
allowed us to scale horizontally and and
create multiple different use cases
instead of having just that single
project there was one more technical
challenge we had to deal with though and
this is this is maybe diving a little
deeper
again we've kind of hand waved again how
we got data vendor data securely into
the project if you want to learn
about that weekend we can talk about it
off to its but it's fairly complex but
the other challenge besides that that we
had to deal with was when you access the
secure API endpoint it actually lives on
a different endpoint the endpoint is
restricted Google API is calm so you
needed a mechanism by which you could
remap any of the calls like for example
Google Cloud Storage is normally storage
so Google API is calm you needed a
mechanism to remap that to restricted
our Google API is calm for your clients
at the time Google's private DNS didn't
didn't exist for us in inside of the VPC
so we couldn't use that and we also
needed a solution for our internal
network so again we went into some
research this time we didn't travel
Google with us we we solved this one
ourselves
but we learned that within our own
internal DNS infrastructure there wasn't
a mechanism for this called response
policy zones so RPC is what it's known
as we implemented that and we were good
to go any requests for Google API as
we're now hitting the restricted
endpoints and our users will get yeah so
in conclusion this was a real game
changer for us having private access to
the api's directly from our on our
internal network enabled researchers to
get up and running and access to the
native tools that we ultimately wanted
to roll out across other teams and
unsurprisingly after we did this we
found many internal teams we're coming
to whistle wanting to make make use of
what this capability gave them and we
expect this to continue as google rolls
out more and more services into BBC
service controls so if you're interested
as an interested in hearing anything
more about this at a deeper level come
talk to us afterwards we'll be outside
and if you think any of this sounds
interesting we're hiring
so that um will hand over to Bernie to
talk about Google's partner ecosystem
thank you thank you so you guys heard a
lot of great stuff that you know our
Google has been building the key
security concept and features that you
can use in addition to what Google bills
there are partners security companies
that you know all of you have been
working for years and years we also work
closely with those security companies to
make sure their solutions can complement
what Google can do so you can seamlessly
use those products so I will cover how
we are working with partners and how
they complement what Google does in
terms of security so the most important
concept to understand first is the
shared security model I wanted to
re-emphasize that at the start so
security at the core infrastructure
level would be something that Google
will provide for you at the
infrastructure level but for your
services your projects you know you have
to think about how you would secure it
you know leveraging the technology that
Google is is building and layering on
partner products on top of that so you
have to think about clearly in terms of
you know what things are covered by
Google at the infrastructure level what
is your responsibility and how do you
you know cover that have a security
policy to do that so there are a lot of
Google products as I mentioned there are
also partner products that complement
this is an eye chart you know I wouldn't
cover all the boxes but there are a
couple of areas or categories that I
would emphasize for example the next-gen
firewall category right they have been
around for a long time you know most
companies use them it's a kind of
category of products that complement
what Google do and you know you can
think of you know hardware security
module as an example is another category
that companies use especially in the
banking sector so you can use those
products in addition to what Google
provides natively to meet different
requirements that you have you know it
could be regulatory requirements could
be you know you're comfortable using a
product from a partner and you want to
continue and extend that product into
your GCP deployments you can absolutely
do that so you know think about you know
how you can layer on the partner
products
what Google provides so other just kind
of sharing can the ecosystem we have it
partners over the last you know one year
we have grown at four X in terms of
security companies so a huge increase in
terms of security leading names in
security who have solutions a broad
category of partners so you know and
pretty much all the big names in
security that you can think of any
product that you use in security works
with GCP now so you can think about you
know which categories are relevant in
your business which products you are
comfortable using and can absolutely go
use those products and most of these
products are listed on the Google GCP
marketplace so you can look at the
marketplace products that are available
or you know work with the partners and
ask them you know how do they support
GCP so I will just not go through all
the categories over just click double
click on few categories that are very
important especially for folks who are
you're new to GCP so with the next-gen
firewalls that I mentioned before you
know app level visibility the hybrid
connectivity from cloud to there aren't
your on-prem deployments are very common
use cases that we see pretty much you
know all major next-generation firewalls
are supported on GCP and it's not only
supporting them and having their
firewall run as a VM in GCP or working
very closely with leading security
companies to build next generation of
security solution so and not just match
what used to happen on prem but how do
we make security better by working with
security companies how do we do it in a
more scalable fashion more automated
able fashion so a lot of interesting
stuff a lot of interesting innovation
happening with these partners and one
key concept is that works very well with
these next-gen firewalls is the shared
VPC concept so if you guys haven't
looked at it it's a very seamless way of
routing all your traffic to a next-gen
firewall having controls at the host
project level and the service projects
will be routed all the traffic will be
routed to your host project so it's a
very unique Google feature that works
very well with a next-gen firewalls I
had been talking to customers and
partners and the comments I got was this
is closest we have
into getting the controls we used to
have on premon in a public cloud
environment so if you haven't looked at
it please do look at it it's a very
strong and useful feature so next
category I want to talk about was
application security so you know as you
think about how do I protect against
application level DDoS attacks
väth kind of functionality in s
mentioned about cloud armor so we have a
lot of flexibility in this category as
an example you could use cloud armor the
native rules that we have on cloud armor
you could have partner rules that
partners are generating and ingest them
into cloud armor you could have a DNS
based valve or DNS based application
DDoS protection solution so you don't
deploy anything it's deployed outside of
Google cloud or you could use a VM based
solution so there are lot of lot effect
flexibility a lot of options available
depending on your requirements you know
your preferences you can pick any of the
options that are available so next
category that's kind of very unique to
cloud is get the compliance in the cloud
category these are cloud native
solutions you know companies like red
lock dome line and others that will help
you when once you are deployed you want
to get a quick check on how where do you
stand in terms of your PCI compliance so
they can go in do a quick check and say
hey you are compliant or you these rules
need to be changed to make you more PCI
compliant so this makes your life much
easier so if you compare this with
on-prem world where you know everything
had to be done
you know largely manually these are the
kind of partners who can bring in you
know if you're just creating a service
account they can generate reports within
minutes to tell you where you are so
this helps to kind of get you more
compliant you know another layer of
checks that you can layer in so other
key concept I wanted to share was in a
cloud security command center it's a
great tool that Google has built that
you guys may have seen some of the
sessions regarding cloud security
command center but this is one place
where all the thread date or all the
kind of visibility of what services what
kind of resources you are using and you
can consolidate all the thread data all
the analysis Google runs on security in
the command center and also add partner
products on top of that so this would be
your one place in GCP where you can get
all the Google signal
you'll get all the partner signals to
see in one dashboard what's going on so
this is you know great innovation
simplifies your life so one place to get
a security posture and we are working
closely with companies to kind of take
it to the next level as well so once you
have the visibility you know how do you
make make it easier for you to kind of
react to that data that you have the dad
I already kind of closed on with you
know just rehashing I think what we
discussed in this session I think think
about when you're thinking about
security as initially mentioned think
about security you know right from you
know the perimeter and from your edge to
core of your network and when you're
creating security rules think of
security rules from coarse-grain to kind
of fine-grained security rules the
service controls are kind of great
addition they're providing great
capabilities to get you kind of the next
level of security and and think about
layering on partner solutions of a big
ecosystem of partners they provide great
capabilities you know think about
leveraging them as well thank you now we
have I think time for a few questions if
anybody has questions
[Music]